Luke says, I bought the Xpire domain from a roofer who let Xpire.
He rebranded.
I'm thinking of reaching out to them, but it's in California.
You recommend against California and roofing.
So I'm wondering if it's two, just two bad things.
I'm thinking of reaching out.
Yeah, reach out, dude.
I only like, the only reason I say avoid California is there's easier places to make money.
But if you can find a spot that has like, I would go and research that person's city.
How is the competition?
How many leads are there actually flowing through that city?
Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Okay.
That's what I would do.
And then you can make that decision.
I don't think it's the worst thing ever.
I just think it's not the greatest use of your time if you have another option.
Okay.